my new study highlights how sexism and
gender attitudes affect earnings and job
prospects for women in the u.s.
researchers analyzed responses to
decades of statistics and survey
questions about women's roles in society
they found where a woman is born impacts
how much she works and earns sexist
attitudes are most prevalent in the
southeast and least prevalent on the
west coast and in New England women from
states where sections in sexism is more
widespread also tend to get married and
have children at a younger age than
women in less sexist States CBS News
contributor Jody Kanter is an
investigative reporter for The New York
Times and has extensively covered sexism
and the meet to movement Jody good
morning good morning even the
researchers who were involved said they
were surprised by the findings well I
think the first piece of news is that
you can even draw a map of sexism in the
United States the researchers were
pretty confident in saying well the West
Coast is less success they even did
state-by-state comparisons they said
Ohio is better and Indiana is worse I
thought was also interesting it was not
only how you are as a woman treated by
others but how you internalize your self
attitudes about the role of women in the
workplace in society the headline from
the study is basically that sexism is in
the water where you're born it's in your
blood
obviously something where you're born is
not something you can control so this is
something you inherit that may determine
part of the shape of your life and that
it's very hard to permanently overcome
even if say you grow up someplace more
rural supposedly more sexist according
to the study and then you move to New
York City you can't totally shake the
effect what are they
what are those correlations between the
status of your growing up and does race
play a role here well they actually only
focused on white women because they
essentially wanted to they knew that the
effect of racism was so powerful that
they wanted to put it aside and focus on
gender in this particular survey but
what they're really saying is that the
effects are quite deep and wide-ranging
everything from when you marry to when
you go to work how much you work whether
you stay in the workplace and how much
money you earn well the solution for
women especially in 2018 shouldn't be
that you have to
we've spent some time you think so much
time talking about how women should
present themselves what the questions
they should be asking how they ask for a
raise how does this impact women in the
workforce in general where we still see
income inequality well one thing I think
we have to point out to be fair is this
is about people who are probably our age
right who were born generations ago
before the internet grew up in a
different era and right now I think
little kids are growing up with more of
an expectation of seeing two career
marriages and women working so it'd be
very curious about what the results of
this study would look like in 30 or 40
years but I think part of the takeaway
is just about the way we think of the
barriers a few years ago the kind of
lean in ideas were more popular the idea
that if you just worked hard enough and
asserted yourself more and we're really
ambitious you could overcome some of
these things and I think this study is
very of the moment and that it's really
capturing a lot of current thinking
saying there are these gigantic
structural barriers that are very
difficult to overcome as an individual
there's another talking about why women
find it so hard to work after they have
babies the talks about things like the
cost of child care it's one up sixty
five or seventy percent since the 1980s
that is a giant barrier that people find
very difficult to overcome on an
individual basis let's ask you about the
Harvey Weinstein story because you broke
that in the New York Times and now we
learned that one of Harvey's accusers is
our gender herself has paid out money to
someone who accused her of sexual abuse
and harassment talk about whether that
sourcing meaning affects it all the
larger story about the me2 movement and
abuse sure so this is a really shocking
story not only because OCR Argento
accused Harvey Weinstein of sexual abuse
but because she was such a leading voice
of the me2 movement and she went out
there and said these things even knowing
that there was this very disturbing
settlement against her so The Times
reported this on Sunday night and it's
caused a huge stir as you know the thing
that I think is important for
texts though is that Argento is one
woman in what's become a huge movement
and even she didn't come forward to us
about Harvey while she was not a source
in here she was in New York surprise she
was in The New Yorker but I can tell you
that you know Megan Chui and I spoke to
so many women who had the same story
about Weinstein we corroborated these
stories very thoroughly
so Weinstein and his team their strategy
is really to focus on Argento now right
they're gonna say she's a hypocrite this
proves that the charges against
Weinstein are really exaggerated but she
is just one voice of very very many how
do you hold that defense though and on
the other hand you say I understand that
my havior behavior was bad how can you
hold those two things if your Weinstein
say both of those things I understand my
behavior was bad but this source is a
bad source so I shouldn't be held
accountable Harvey Weinstein is fighting
two battles now he's fighting to get the
court shot he wants to be the criminal
charges right he doesn't want to go to
jail he doesn't want to be convicted of
sexual abuse he's also fighting to
redeem his reputation and those two
things are linked so what I'm gonna tell
you to look out for in current month in
the next few months is him waging that
war on both fronts and so he wants to
beat the charges but he also wants to
change the way we think about makes you
movement far from over Jodi Kanter thank
you so much for joining us thank you